I have a gluten sensitivity,
and my husband and I visited Europe last year,
and it was really interesting
because all of the gluten that I ate over there,
I digested fine.
I didn't have any reactions to it.
Instead of just doing gluten free things,
today, I actually ordered flour from Italy,
and we're gonna make a sourdough starter with it,
and we're gonna see how this goes.
This is kind of an experiment,
and if my body does not react well to it,
that's okay.
My husband can eat all of the sourdough,
and he will be very happy about it.
To do 100 grams of this flour.
Now we're gonna add 100 grams of spring water.
I have my little sourdough starter,
and now we will wait about 24 hours
and then feed it again.